was mir mittlerweile auf allen social
media ist einfach so kraft geworden es
ist eine unglaublich tolle plattform
aber mittlerweile nutzt das jeder um
sich darzustellen sich auch darzustellen
wie man tatsächlich auch nicht ist jedes
model jeder ist voll jeder schön jeder
ist keine ahnung was also ich meine das
ist viele vergessen auch modeln ist ein
job und wo man muss abliefern können und
und kam mit photoshop hin oder her ich
habe auch mal irgendwie nicht wirklich
oder so weg ge photoshop das ist auch
klar und das käme auch wörtlich zu aber
dann noch zusätzlich kommt noch dazu
dass man dann auch mittlerweile auf
instagram so krass die leute sage ich
jetzt mal hintergeht seine follower
schafft hintergeht indem man dinge auch
verkauft und sonstige erst am am tag das
produkt am anderen tag das und ich merke
dass auch extrem zum beispiel meine
follower schafft wenn ich was poster
über kunst und kultur oder etwas
interessant dass auch was politisches
habe ich sofort zwar und dafür weniger
wo ich mich dann okay wenn ich im bikini
bild hochladen würde wie man sie andere
instagram blogger tatsächlich da da
schießt in die höhe und dass sich
gesellschaftlich dass es irgendwie auch
schon ein bisschen komisch ist
das interesse auch ein bisschen geht ich
meine unterhaltung ist das ein ding aber
ich meine man kann sich darauf für die
dinge aber interessiert haben auch
einfach sich weiterbilden und das finde
ich ein ganz schwieriges thema weil die
meisten verbringen so viel zeit auf
instagram das ist auch extrem einfluss
auch nimmt wenn die alleine der schule
hocken und auf dem handy irgendwo
versteckt instagram anschauen verbringen
sie ihre zeit lieber irgendwie jemand
anzuschauen und nachzuahmen der folge
photoshop ist und auch teilweise ein
leben hat was gar nicht so wirklich ist
und haben das als ziel lebensziel
stattdessen und eine preisträgerin zum
beispiel die gewisse irgendwie auf ihre
arbeiten wissenschaftliche arbeiten auf
preise bekommen hat zum beispiel solche
leute werden nicht werden nicht sag ich
jetzt mal sind nicht so fasst sie hier
von solchen leuten und das finde ich
irgendwie schon krass wie irgendwie sich
so dienst zu gehören ist gefährlich
jetzt schaffe ich die perfekte brücke zu
ihnen helfen damit sie mir nicht böse
sind da sie unterbrechen musste ist
instagram vielleicht gefährlicher sogar
noch für die jugend ausländern ist naja
wenn wir über das thema cybermobbing und
so weiter sprechen das ist nunmal
gravierend
was
früher war also zwei jahren ja die
verbale gewalt zu stimmen sie auch war
die war auf dem schulhof im schulbereich
und jetzt trägt sie so zu wird sie nach
hause getragen und so was wie instagram
das mandat da sind dann die models das
ist so das ideal meisters ist so das
bild da wird ja auch bild transportiert
übrigens was dann wieder auch glaube ich
weiter geht ich hatte gerade mit ein
paar handwerkern auch darüber gesprochen
dass die kann keinen nachwuchs finden ja
warum bei irgendwas mit irgendwas mit
medien bei youtube oder instagram machen
da macht man ein paar fotos und dann
verdient man mehrere milliarden euro das
ist ja was also
sind es vielleicht ein paar milliarden
aber fakt ist dass das natürlich im
bereich ist wobei ganz dort aufpassen
müssen weil wir auch da wieder nicht
hinterher kommen weil da technisch zum
beispiel wenn es mit internet
kriminalität verbunden ist wenn ich
daran denke was für polizei arbeitet wie
die beschränkt wird weil die nicht genug
rechner haben hinterher zu sein und so
weiter und dass es dann zu viel wird und
es um auch wieder da bin ich wieder beim
thema kinder und jugendliche zu sagen
wie sie da tatsächlich geschützt werden
und wer dann auch sagt in so einer
verantwortlichen position passt mal auf
das ist auch gefährlich alleine schon
das suchtpotenzial finde ich das richtig
weil klar man kann es juristisch
nachbearbeiten und hinterher gehen aber
dann ist meistens das kind im wasser
worte schon im mund gefallen herr
partien statt die videos zu produzieren
wollen sie jetzt vielleicht influenza
werne scheint ja sehr lukrativ zu sein
das bin ich schon für den winter
bedeuten sondern influenza geht darum
wie menschen verreisen für wie viele
folgen denn in den sozialen medien das
ist nur eine zahl von klagen sie darauf
installiert ist das nicht wichtig denke
ich ich glaube eher instagram wird hier
gerade instrumentalisiert für ein
größeres problem weil nicht die app ist
das problem und es gibt ja mehrere
dienste der macht süchtig zigaretten und
alkohol und war auch dass depression
potenzial bei ich habe darüber auch ein
buch geschrieben und spreche habe ich
mich lange damit auseinandergesetzt und
dass depression potenzial bei jungen
menschen das sehr hoch das macht süchtig
und da gibt es wirklich viele glauben ja
nicht so gerne einen studien aber das
ganze sehr gern hier in definiert sind
was er mit tik tok oder facebook also
wie viel der vergleichswert
psychologisches institut siebenjähriger
als beispielsweise facebook tik tok war
damals noch nicht so weit oben jetzt
habe ich damals nicht verglichen aber
sie sind also instagram ist kein problem
für junge menschen das habe ich nicht
gesagt auf jeden fall ist nur bleiben
weil es einen zugang zu social media ist
daher sage ich das quasi nur eine app
von vielen und ich glaube es geht eher
um den bewussten umgang das ist so die
dunkle seite des social medias er mit
dem negativen psychologischen aspekt und
aber auch der werbebranche weil im tv
ist es nicht anders wenn ich eine
anfrage an gegen den prominenten sende
und sage ich etwas auf was du lust auf
die werbung dieses produkt zu bewerben
dann ist genau dasselbe ob er das ist am
handymarkt und am tv am handy sind die
follower nur näher dran und da ändert
sich das gefüge quasi zum vorgehen es
gibt ein anderes problem der riders mit
dem fernseher mit zeitung machen viele
den vergleichen das problem dabei ist
bei instagram haben die menschen das
gefühl das ist mein bester freund ist
meine beste lieben ja genau wie
psychologie liegt in berlin die nur
dafür angestellt sind dass menschen
länger zeit auf instagram verbringen und
dementsprechend beim fernsehen zum
beispiel sind jetzt nicht psychologen
angestellt damit man länger einer person
folgt also es ist wirklich nachweislich
so dass vor allem das problem ist dieser
beste freundin faktor die werbung steht
oben ganz klein ist wenn ich in der
werbepause abgegeben werbung und content
läuft fließender ineinander über aber
wir sehen sie das denn herr plus die
nachteile über die wir ihm gesprochen
haben die sehe ich natürlich auch
trotzdem haben die sozialen netzwerke
auch vorteile also wenn ich zum beispiel
bei meinen politischen kanal die leute
auch mal richtig mitnehmen kann ins
regierungsviertel in den bundestag rein
auf fragen kann was ist eure meinung
dazu welche themen interessieren euch
kann ich das sehr gut über instagram
machen oder über andere social media
kanäle und das kann ich über so eine
klassische zeitungen oder auch über das
fernsehen in der form nicht machen daher
gibt es auch schon vorteile oder ins ein
schönes schlusswort